c'est long tête à tête où l'on fait la
tendresse où l'on est femme a des rôles
de maîtresse quand les planches
rencontrent les champs c'est ce que
propose le Comité Départemental
d'animation et de théâtre amateurs des
Yvelines avec la seconde édition de
théâtre à la ferme cela ne s'apprend pas
cette affaire de race on peut acquérir
l'arme et non le naturel par l'étude on
devient ce que fut la Rachel qui donne
sera souvent roi d'où prétentieuse
toujours fort dramatique qui n'est
jamais gracieuse c'est inattendu c'est
vrai que on vient visiter une
exploitation on vient acheter pourquoi
pas des produits et légumes bio locaux
et puis on se retrouve assez à regarder
une pièce de théâtre donc c'est vraiment
très surprenant et très agréable je
trouve que c'est très sympa comme comme
formule voilà théâtre à la ferme on est
dans la nature et on a un peu de culture
donc c'est bien tes représentations
théâtrales gratuites et tout public dans
un cadre bucolique pour le plaisir du
texte et du lieu les différentes troupes
du comité joueront des classiques du
théâtre français tel Cyrano de Bergerac
ou les Fables de La Fontaine mais à la
ferme des Mureaux c'est Guy de
Maupassant et Max Moret qui étaient à
l'honneur l'événement offre à la ferme
une occasion de se faire connaître et de
rendre le théâtre plus accessible on
essaye d'amener le théâtre directement
en fait au contact du public pour pour
pouvoir lui redonner goût en fait à
revenir dans les salles après la
représentation c'est découverte de la
ferme avec des visites organisées
différents producteurs présentent leurs
produits eufray fruits de saison ou
fromage fermier majoritairement issus de
l'agriculture biologique sont proposés
des animations sont également prévues
pour les enfants je viens de découvrir
un peu les produits
tous nos légumes les fruits les fruits
les produits des partenaires les
biscuits le miel le fromage
théâtre à la ferme est une initiative
originale elle permet de découvrir la
richesse des exploitations agricoles des
Yvelines carte fermes sont concernées
une belle occasion de se divertir se
cultiver et soutenir les producteurs
locaux le festival se déroule jusqu'au
25 juin